j'ai trouvé sur les bus mais l'écriture
et leur au passage aux autres est un
personnage dans la maison en flammes et
des nuages
j'ai décidé des fenêtres des tableaux
des personnages leurs pompiers prennent
vie pour porter secours à
l'environnement cette classe de cm2 de
versailles participe à la sixième
édition de l'agenda scolaire un projet
pluridisciplinaire autour des déchets on
a travaillé en sciences on a travaillé
en production d'écrits on a travaillé en
recherche
mais la finalité c'est d'arriver à ses
planchers au travail voilà ça c'est la
finalité du projet pour aller aux jeux
aux éco-gestes faut d'abord connaître et
comprendre les enjeux qu'il ya derrière
pour vous prenez une bouteille de jus
d'orange le matin il faut réfléchir de
façon systémique d'où lui vient comme on
les crée
comment il a été produit et qu'elles
vont être cédés chez près 220 enfants
quatre classes de l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc ont travaillé deux
jours avec un bédéiste cette année c'est
stedo dessinateur belge
alors ils ont plein d'idées plus que moi
du coup c'est un peu frustrant mais non
mais je suis je suis assez surpris parce
que c'est quand même un projet concerne
conséquent au niveau du boulot à
investir et je trouve qu'ils ont plein
d'idées ils sont très réactifs
il dessine vachement bien en fait donc
voilà je pense que je vais les engager
les élèves ont donné avant les vacances
leur dernier coup de crayon plus de dix
mille exemplaires de cet agenda seront
distribués dès le mois de juin